Speaker 1: I have another chapter for you.
In the MAGA revolt that is taking place,
I told you last week that what used
to be pro-Trump and anti-Trump clashes
within the Republican Party have now become
pro-Trump versus formerly pro-Trump elements
of the Republican Party. And this is really,
really good for the left because the left has
very little going for it right now when it comes
to national political office and campaigning,
as I've told you before. There's this former
Republican U.S. Senate candidate Daniel McCarthy,
and we played one clip of him last week. I'll
play it in a bit, but I have a new clip of him.
This is fascinating. This is not only a
former MAGA guy. It's a former MAGA guy
who has woken up to exactly the truth about
Donald Trump. He's a fraud. He's a sham and
he's a liar. Now mixed in with that, there's all
sorts of lies that Daniel McCarthy still believes,
but it's incredible how what we've known all
along about Trump. This guy is now waking up to
listen. Listen, read between the lines, right?
I mean, you know, you have to understand this
guy's still a radical right winger. But listen
to the critique he loves about Donald Trump here.
Speaker 3: So I want make it clear to all you
people out there that potentially watching
this that are, you know, kind of haters in
regards to, oh yeah, or Trump or Trump. Part
of a master operation or some some 4D chess
or any of that nonsense. No, Trump is a fraud.
Speaker 1: That's fascinating. For years, these
MAGA people like this guy were when Trump would
seemingly do something harebrained. They would
say, this guy is playing some version of 40 chess.
He's got all the moves figured out in advance. And
now Daniel McCarthy is like, There's no 40 chess.
The guy is genuinely a fraud. And he's right.
Speaker 3: You were brought in. Yes.
And it's time to move on quickly.
Speaker 1: I think the term is defrauded,
but I mean, he's right. He's completely right.
And the Republicans should move on quickly is a
Speaker 3: scam and it's can and expose him
as a sham and move on. And potentially he
should be held accountable like the
rest of these criminals. Yes, I have
perpetrated this fraud on the American people.
Speaker 1: That's a MAGA, a maggot. I think
sometimes people call them. He has woken up. You
know, you talk about going woke. He has become
woke to the sham and scam and fraud that is Donald
Trump. And it's amazing that it took this long,
but he's absolutely and completely right. I
mean, there's there's just no way around it now.
This is the clip from last week, and here
you'll see you'll see the MAGA shine through
because Daniel McCarthy dips in and out of
statements that makes sense and complete and
utter lies. Remember this?
Speaker 2:
Hey, Donald Trump, this is Daniel McCarthy in
Arizona. The world is waking up to your massive
grift. Please stop with the smoke and mirrors
with these audits. Stop with your fundraising.
Yes. Stop establishment candidate endorsement
through. Stop pushing this gene therapy.
Speaker 1: Now there he goes off the
rails. The vaccines are not gene therapy.
Speaker 2: The source I hear
you're coming to Florence, Arizona,
for another one of your do nothing rah rah
Speaker 1: rah session rallies. That's exactly
what they are. They are do nothing rah rah
rallies here. He's completely right about that.
Speaker 2: Well, I have an offer for you. I will
give $1 million to the charity of your choice.
If you take 30 minutes of your stage time on
January 15th and debate me or answer my question
to you in front of your crowd. Think about all
the things that you've done that you've got
you've not been held accountable
for. You ushered in medical tyranny.
Speaker 1: No, that's not true.
Speaker 2: You exploded our national debt.
Speaker 1: That is true.
Speaker 2: You relinquished our
sovereignty with the USMCA trade deal.
Speaker 1: That is untrue.
Speaker 2: You passed more gun laws
than Obama did with fixed NICS.
Speaker 1: Unclear.
Speaker 2: You warned
about election fraud. But yet you did nothing to
prevent it. Even after my team months in advance
warned you, after we were stolen from in the
Senate primary, you gave up on therapeutics
and you push an experimental gene therapy.
Speaker 1: OK, anyway. So he didn't push
experimental gene therapy or anything like that.
And as I played for you last week, this guy
ultimately uses a flamethrower to burn the MAGA
hat. So listen, I it's it's horrible that this
is what we have to look at as signs of light, but
this is really good for the left. It's not just
pro and anti-Trump Republicans, it's formally
pro-Trump Republicans turning against Trump. We
want this happening right now. Some Trumpists have
abandoned Trump. Alex Jones is furious with Trump.
Former MAGA guy Daniel McCarthy is furious Trump
is feuding with Mitch McConnell, and he's still
attacking his own former Vice President Mike
Pence. This is a good thing, and it will be very
interesting to see the approach that Trump takes
at this weekend's rally. We'll be live with it.
Trump speaks at 9:00 p.m. East. We will be live at
8:00 p.m. Eastern on all of our online platforms.
And I hope that you'll join me. Send me your
thoughts about this. Find me on Twitter at
David Pakman and let me know what you think
about Trump on former Trump violence. The
David Pakman Show depends directly on the support
of our viewers and listeners. Grab a membership
at Join Packman CNN.com. We have so much to
cover. I won't even say more about membership.